では よろしくお願いします
はい まあ今日のテーマはこの命が一日だったらどうしましょうか？という
仏教でお釈迦様がおっしゃっている
この不死なるということはね
まあそれは説明したいんですけど
これはもうすごい難しくて
まあ説明しないことにする
まあできるだけわかりやすいところだけ取り上げて説明させていただきます
で 順番変えて まずはあの
まず仏教の話をしてから
一般の世間の考え方説明します
ですから このテーマ聞いたところで
ちょっと考え方あると思いますけど
皆様聞きたがっていることは
ある あのイギリス 英語の雑誌に昔読んだ記事なんですけど
ある女性がね 末期ガンだと宣告されて
まあ聞いたところで まあ初めにはすごくまあショックになりましたと
でもすぐ開き直って この短い一日
日々をね いかにみんなと家族と他のみんなと仲良く楽しく有効に過ごせるのかということだけ考えたんだと
そこでまあすごく楽しくなったと
みんなも無茶親切でなりまして
まあ子供たちもすごい親切に自分に接したり
自分も滅多なことには混乱したり
まあ何もなかったと 普段はすごくカンカン怒ることやら
神経質になることやら
しょっちゅう怒るんですけど
全然そんな無駄な時間過ごす必要ないっていうことで
すごく穏やかに 生きてるんだっていうふうな
彼女が書いた記事でしたけど
まあ皆さんもそういう話を聞きたいんですけど
まあ言わない そんなのはそういう人に見えるもんだから
なんで私が言わなくちゃいけないんですか？私が言うことは私にしかできないことなんです
で それはお釈迦様のまずですから
ブッダの世界はお釈迦様自身がどうやってこの問題を見てみるのかということにします
まず仏教が見るのは この唯一確かな現象
人は死ぬということだけ
この世の中で確実なものは何一つもないんです
それだけでも大変な考え方なんですよ
この世の中で この千存在の中で
たった確かなことっていうのは
たった一つ死ぬっていうこと
必ず壊れる どんなものでも
絶対止まることはないんだと
永遠とか全くあり得もしない嘘で見ているんです
それで 死がこの世でたった一つの確かなものです
人はこれだけ絶対ありえないと目を背く
人間の立場が全く反対で
絶対それだけありえないと
死ぬっていうことだけは
たったこれだけ絶対的に確実なのに
それに背いてるんですよ
だから生命っていうのは無知だと言ってるんですよ
背いた背いたっても もう死しか存在しないんだから
どこ見てるんでしょうかと
例えば我々は空気の中に来てるでしょうね
空気は嫌いだとか もう後ろ向いたら何を見てるんで？空気の方を見ているでしょうに
では左に曲がってみるぞと
で 左に空気がない それでまた空気に向かっているでしょうに
どこ見たっても 顔はまっすぐ空気に合わせてるでしょうに
そんな感じで人には背くことできるものじゃないんだけど
そんなつもりでいるんです
人生生きるというのは
いかに死を避けるかという必死な努力のことです
それで誰一人も生きるということは何のこと全然定義しようとしない
ごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃいろんなことを言うんですよ
でも具体的に生きるということは
死を避けることなんです
死が避けられませんよ
避けられないが まあくたびれて死ぬまではもうなんとかなんとかなんとかなんとか動かしてはいるんです
それに生きるということを言うんですよ
だから生きる上では恐怖
不安 怯え 落ち込み 欲 怒り
憎しみ 争い であれは肥満でしたっけ
肥満 高慢などで え？まあ単語はないんですけど
作りました で 必ず悩むんです
そういう単語はないんですけど
まあただ自分がすごく惨めで卑しいやつやと思うこと
惨めな思い それは仏教では心理学的には慢に入りますから
まあそうするしかないんです
それでなんで人間にそういう様々なトラブルがあるのかというと
すごいわかりやすい 確実な死がある
そこから逃げ回る 逃げ回ると味方があると思っちゃうと
そこで欲が生まれてくる
例えば 美味しいごちそうに出会っちゃうと
えらい欲が出てきてよだれまで垂らしちゃうんです
それでもう命は繋げると勘違いしているんです
金なんか見ると もう西も東も右もわからなくなっちゃいますね
これで命が助かりそうと思っちゃう
そこで欲が生まれてくる
ライバルがいたり 自分の仕事を奪おうとしたりしている人がいると
ものすごく腹が立ったりする
命 自分にはそれだったら生きていられないってことでしょう
だから このただそのからくりで
あらゆる心の汚れやら煩悩やら落ち込みやら
何らかんでも生まれてくるんです
避けられませんよ だって人は死を避けようとしているんだから
だから仏教でいうこの千五百の煩悩っていうのは当然生まれてくる
それで全ての煩悩は無知というものから土台なんで
無知は だって死は避けられないことだから
避けようとしているんだから
死っていうのはあり得はありとはしないと思っているんだから
それが無知なんです そういうことで
だから死の無視ということを我々やっていますね
無知の証拠 生命が死を無視する
それ自体が無知の証拠なんですね
これらの煩悩で悩むのは
決して死は訪れるはずがないと思う無知があるからです
まあ簡単です 心の中でそういう気持ちがあるんです
死には全像と 死ぬはずがないんだという
それは無知がどんな人でも抱えてます
無知に基づいて築く人生は無意味なものです
それは仏教的な評価で
無知に没頭すぎてね 何を築いたってもろくなことじゃありませんと
だから人間の世界は 仏教は全く無意味でくだらないと言っているんです
人間が何をしても それは無知に基づいているんです
どんな大量破壊兵器を作ったっても
今日読み始めた小説なんですけど
この って こういうことを書いてます
その時はちゃんとこれだけは事実やと書いてるんです
1ページもないんですけどね
他は嘘やと で アンチボディとして反物質でしたっけ
で それはもうどこがどこかでちゃんと発見しているんだと
作っている作ることもできるんだと
それっていうのは不思議なもので
ほんのわずかなアンチボディがあってもすっごいエネルギーですよと
それで効率もすごくよろしいんだと
1グラムぐらいのアンチボディあれば
どれぐらいエネルギーあるかというと
この広島に落とした爆弾ぐらいだと
この反物質があれば同じ物質ですけど
ただ電気系統が逆になっているだけね
で しかし それちょっとした欠点があるんだと
その反物質はこの世で何に触れてもたちまち燃えてしまいますよ
これはすごい便利でした
作ったっても成り立たないんです
しかし これから科学者は研究して
その反物質について 人類
それが人類を作る 救うものになるのか
あるいは今までも想像できなかったほど恐ろしい人殺しの道具にするかということは
科学者の腕にかかっているんだと
それで終わっちゃったんですけど
その文章で 私はまあそんなのは決まってるんだと
まず核兵器を作ることに使うんだよと
もしそれは実用的なレベルに反物質を反物質を作ることができれば
そんなもんだよね 人間やってることは
だから世の中で何を人間作ったっても
結局無知の上で築くもんだから
まあどんとろくなことではありませんというのは仏教的な立場なんです
で 俗世間は憎しみ合い
殺し合い 競争などで構成されたもので
苦難に満ちている 我々知ってる世界っていうのはこんな世界なんです
なんでそんなのあるのかというと
死なんだ 死なないんだぞと思ってるし
その無知で しかし死ぬんだから
どうそれを避ければいいかということで
こんなことばっかしやっているんです
はい 次 でお釈迦様はそれはこういうふうに表現しています
不死だと思う愚か者 パレチャナウィジャナティマヤメッタヤママセ
イエチャタッタウィジャナティタトサンマンティメデガ
あのイエーチャというと
もっとちょっと先スペース入れてください
うん それでこのパレってのは
この他人様 仏教の人 ブッダ以外のね
まあ仏弟子 ブッダ以外の人々のことで
もう全然知らないんだね
ヴィジャなんて知らない
マヤメッタヤママセ ここでももう死んでくたびれるのは我々ではないかということを知らないんだと
結局は イエーチャタッタヴィジャなんて
もし誰かがそれ知っているならば
己が死ぬんだと 知るならば
タトサンマンティメデガ
それが一切の争いの終わりだと
それで人間がすごく平和になるんです
死ぬんだぞということを認めれば
戦い戦う気になりません
憎しみ合う気になりません
ちょっとしたことでも壊れてしまいますから
命は だから大事にしましょうと
卵を運ぶような感じで大事にするんですよ
ちゃんと包装して このガラスとか割れ物とかね
我々は大事に包装して運んだりするでしょう
それは割れるんだからなんです
すごい庭に置く石みたいなものだったら
別に包装でも何でもなく
もうもう転がったり もう上に乗ったり
やりたい放題 それは壊れないという前提だからでしょ
だから乱暴に扱う 壊れるんだというと
乱暴に扱わない だから命は壊れるものだと知らないんだから
世の中でこの愚かどもたちは知らないんだから
世の中は一向に良くならないというのは仏陀の考え方なんです
次いきます で 我々は塩を蒸して喉を潤すということをやっています
決して渇きは消えませんよ
その意味で使っている
まあよく仏教的なことわざです
死ぬはずはないという前提は苦しみを生かす
で 死ぬはずはないという前提で生きているんだから
我々はずっと毎日何をしているかというと
苦しみをしているんです
苦しんでいるんです 何をしても苦しいんですよ
人生は たとえ成功しても
仕事に成功したとか でも苦しいんです
それでも 肉体の維持管理のために必死になる
誰でも何に何をやってるかというと
この肉体の維持管理なんです
これすぐ簡単に壊れますよ
水ぐらいでもあげなかったらかなりくたびれますよ
肉体は だから肉体の維持管理に時間必死なんです
財産名誉のために何でもやる
それも肉体のためなんですよ
財産名誉のためなら何でもやる
自分を守るために躊躇なく他に迷惑をかける
自分を守りたければ 何のこともなく人に迷惑をかける
人殺しもする 自分を守るためにどんな罪も犯す
美容と まあこれはちょっとした余計な言葉で
美容と健康に良いと言われると毒でも飲むと
まあまとめて言えばそんな生き方をしているんですよ
まあ文学的に私なりの文学的に表現すると
だからそんなことでどんどん苦しみが増えるだけ
はい 次に行きます それで我々は老いることを怯える
病気を怯える 物に人に極端に執着する
これで命を守ってくれると思って老いてくるとすごく怯えるので
これで死んじゃうと困りますよと
永遠に若く若く若しくいる方法はないのかと
そういう薬とかいろいろ作ってますよ
全部嘘ですけど 高いお金で買っちゃいます
肉体とその周りのことにしか興味がない
人間の頭が悪いんですよ
自分の肉体とその肉体の関係の周り
目が肉体でしょ 目に見えるもの
それ以外は興味がない
耳に肉体でしょ 耳に聞こえるもの
だから自分のちょっとした周りにしか興味がないので
水の中の魚と同じなんですよ
知識範囲はその中なんですね
例えば小さなグラスの中であの金魚でも育ててみると
買ってみると そいつは知らないのは知ってるのはそのガラスの瓶の中の世界ですよ
それ以外は知りません
それで人間は生きる幸福を失うんです
本当は生きるということは
こんなに苦しいものじゃないんです
でも それを知ったことはありません
誰一人も そんなに楽なのかと
死を無視して死を早める
人間死にたくないんだけど
それであの塩水飲むような感じでやってはいけないことばっかりやることで
かなり精神的にストレス溜まる
あの千五百の煩悩も生まれる
心の中で そこでものすごい死が早まるんです
はい それは例えて言えば
無免許で運転するような感じなんで
無免許は安全ですか？と
俗世間に 無免許だから安全だよと言っていることで
仏教はこれがダメやと言っているんです
人生を運転に例えてみましょうと
人は無免許 無免許で人生を操縦している
肉体は心 精神によって管理されている
それは誰もわからない
認めたくない その心は無知で煩悩に汚れて機能しない
この肉体を管理するべき心がろくに機能していないんですよ
無知で煩悩ですっごく汚れて力能力ないんです
心には 知っていると思っても
それは真理ではなく あべこべの認識です
だから我々は心で物事を知っていると思ってますが
本当はそれあべこべです
主を否定している人々だから
何知ったっても全然それ正しくない
簡単に言えますよ 人間が知っているものがあれば
それは全て間違いやと
その中でブッダはかすかに認めるのはこの道徳的な思考なんですよ
まあ悪いことはしてはいけないとかね
嘘をついてはいけないとか
一般の人々も言っています
それはその通りだとお釈迦様は言うんです
だからって人にすごい頭がいいわけじゃないんで
そんなこと言ったっても
なぜかというと 道徳論の中で自分に迷惑だから良くないと言ってるだけなんです
人が自分に嘘をつくと自分に迷惑なんですよ
人が自分を殴ったり殺したりするとえらい迷惑なんですね
だから殴ってはいけない
殺してはいけないと言うんです
しかし これ 道徳として理解しているわけじゃないんです
それも自己 自己愛から
死にたくないという気持ちから出てくる
いい加減な考え方なんですけど
結論は間違っているわけじゃないんです
お釈迦様が認めるのはそれぐらいの話ですよ
俗世間の知識の中で そこで我々はなんで無免許ということを作ったかというと
肉体を操縦するのは心なんですが
その心はちゃんとした免許を取ってないんです
むちゃくちゃなんです
煩悩で 怒りで 憎しみでものすごく燃えているんです
だったら  例えば たとえ運転免許を持ってる人でも
運転している間で突然体に火がついたらどうなるんですかね
丁寧に車を止まって なんとかすると思いますか？いきなり暴れ回るでしょうね
その瞬間で事故を起こしちゃうでしょうに
だから我々の心はものすごく暴れ回ってますよ
だから死にたくない 死にたくないと思っても
人は誰でも生きていられる寿命よりかなり短い寿命で死ぬんです
かなり短い寿命で死ぬんです
はい 次に行きます 正しいと思って
あ 正しいと思って悪い
正しくないことばかりをする
人間が正しいことだと思ってやっていることは全部正しくないんです
心は煩悩で焼けている
心が支配している肉体も一緒にあぶられています
だから 心が焼いてますからね
燃えていますから 体の中にあるでしょ
体はあぶられてます 結果として
寿命を全うする前に 生きる目的に達する前に死へ暴走する
どんな人でも何をやっているのかというと
死を迎って暴走しているんです
ゆっくり歩けばいいのに
しかし 人間そう思っていないんです
健康にいい食べ物ばっかり探すわ
どんな運動 スポーツすればもう健康でいられるのかも調べるわ
もう必死になってますけど
でもそれっていうのは全部仇になるんです
はい 次 幸福と安らぎの玄関
死は確実で避けられないものだと知る
死は確実で決して避けられないものだと知ると
その瞬間から幸福になりますよ
認めた瞬間からものすごいリラックスできます
いまだ死に出会わず生きていることがこと自体が不思議で
奇跡だと だからその人は
死は突然訪れる嫌なものではなくて
生きていること自体が奇跡だよと
今日もよく生きてるんだと
だから朝目が覚めたら不思議でたまらん
あら まだ死んでないんだと
ああ よかったと もうかったと
そういう風にすごく楽しく生きていられますよ
知らないと思っちゃうと
朝目覚めると嫌なんですよ
今日あれやらなくちゃ
これやらなくちゃ もうなんやこれやと
死ぬのは当たり前のことだ
それぐらいは知ってると思ってる方々もいるでしょうが
まあこれは反論なんですけど
まあ例えばこのこんなこと言うと
皆様の方からはね 人は死ぬっていうことは俺ぐらい
それぐらい知ってるぞと
馬鹿にするんじゃないよという気分にもなりますよ
それは事実ですか？と
事実じゃないんです 皆様に質問されても
皆様方は堂々と答えますよ
まあそれはその通りよ
人は死にますよと あなたは私も死にますよと堂々と言うんです
でも本当のこと言ってるわけじゃないんです
あれは嘘をついてるんです
はい 次 は抜けてます 死は当たり前だと思っても
自分の死を認めがたい
死は当たり前だと言ってはいるんだけど
自分の死ということは全然認めませんね
認めたくない 考えたこともない
宣告されると怯えたり
悩んだり 恐怖感を抱いたりする
だから 例えば病気になって末期になって医者が宣告しちゃうと
ものすごくショックを受けるんですよ
なんででしょうかね 当たり前のことだから
そんなに怯えることないでしょうに
確実に死ぬんだから でも怯えるでしょ
ということは そんなはずではなかったという意味なんです
がんは手遅れと言われると
なんで私はもうちょっと前に診察しなかったのかとかね
なんで医者がもう去年も
あの なんとか なんて言いますか
人間ドックに行ったのに見つからなかったんですか？とか
そうやって怒ったりするっていうことは
知らないという前提でいるということなんです
親しい人の死を嘆き悲しむ
また忘れがたい なんで我々は親しい人が亡くなるとすごく悲しくなるのかというと
死んでほしくないだからなんです
そんなこと欲しくないと言ったって人は死ぬんだから
結局は認めてないんですよ
だからすごく親しい人が死ぬと
ものすごく我慢できなくなるんです
1 日でも長生きできれば幸福だと思う
それでどんな人でも  1 日でも長生きすれば幸福だと思っているんです
それはありえない話なんです
いつ死ぬかわからないんだから
口先で何を言っても人は死を認めない
ですから 俗世間ではまあもう生命はね
まあ死ぬべきものやとか堂々と言うんだけど
あれは本当の真理ではございません
ただごまかしを言ってるだけ
死ぬっていうことを本当に認めると
誰が死んだってすごく冷静にいられるはずなんです
親が 死んでも子供が死んでも死んだのか
それでいられるはずなんです
だから認めてないんですよ
皆様に親の死は死なんかは全く冷静で見ていられますかね
それはできないでしょうね
すごく悲しくなるでしょうね
だからそれは認めたくない
認めてないっていうことの心の底ではい
騙し合いで舞い上がる
だから人間っていうのは互いに騙し合ってよく舞い上がっているんです
戦争もするわ 殺されるのに大成功やと
様はでしたっけ このテロ掃討作戦は大成功でしたと言いながら
みんないまだに殺されています
ガンの告知は認めない
受け入れる準備はない
それも騙し合いでしょ
医者は言わない 本人に
騙してるでしょうに それで肝心の患者さんが何の準備もできなくなっちゃうんです
親族には言うかもしれませんだけど
本人には言わない それで騙し合っています
人は死ぬのではなく 天に召される
成仏する 他界する 往生するものですね
死ぬんじゃないんです
いかに騙して 何言ってるんですか
我々は言わないよ あの人
あの人死にましたとかね
言わないでしょ 親しい人の自分の死を嫌がるが
処分したい人の死を期待する
そんなものすごい残酷なんですよ
親しい人の死だってはものすごく嫌がるんですよ
しかし 嫌な人々は殺す
死んじゃうとえらく喜ぶんです
いかに人間っていうのは残酷でも悪いかというと
イラクにしたっても この
テロ行為をやっている人々は
もう何人がこれぐらい死んで
これぐらい殺された 殺した
これぐらい殺したとずいぶん威張っているし
アメリカ軍隊もまあこれぐらい人を殺した
これぐらいテロをやっつけたとか
人を殺して楽しむんです
で 自分の誰かがこれ死んじゃうと
えらくそれにまた立ち上がっちゃうんです
なんて残酷なことをやっているでしょうかとか
何言うんでしょうかと
私 仏教は言うんですよ
ものすごい人間というのは残酷なんです
それも死を否定しているんだから起こる出来事なんです
事実を認められない無知と精神的な弱みが騙し合いの原因
それで我々は嫉妬や事実は認めないでしょう
それは無知ですね それで精神的にはもう弱い
死を認めるぐらいの強さがない
その 2つがあるんです
無知と弱み この無知と弱みがあるんだから
この騙し合いはずっと続くんです
次のポイント 真理を認める人は強い
だから真理を認められるならば
ものすごい強いんです
それをどのように認めるかというと
水に書いた禅のごとく
弾ける泡のごとく それはいろいろ経典やらいろんな仏教の作品いっぱいあります
そこからあっちこっちから引っ張った言葉なんです
弾ける泡のごとく 昇る太陽は必ず沈むごとく
他も自分も死を目指して走るという事実を認める
私も毎日毎日どこへ向かって歩んでいるのかというと
死を向かって歩んでいる
歩んでいるのよと それで自分の国では冗談がありますよ
よく我々よく言いますよ
君どこへ行くの？あ 死へ行くんだよと
何のことなく言うんです
人はどこに行くのかと場所を聞いてますけど
いきなりあ まあ死へ行きますと
まあ怒られますけど 馬鹿にされたんだから
しかし それは仏教的な表現で
人はどこへ行くのかというと
全体的に言えばもう死ということなんです
吸った息を必ず吐くように
生あるものは死すのですということ
そういう風に納得してもらわないとダメなんです
これは仏教であるものすごくたくさん表現がありまして
もうそれはもうほとんど暗記するんですよ
パワードディープトゥーラエサユサンとティアーキャン
もう風がね 例えばこの炎にね
風が当たると消えてしまうやと
そのように我々の寿命もちょっとした風が吹くとなくなるんだと
マハーサンパジェサンパタヤタサッタマタイで
いくら財産があっても人は死ぬんだよと
タターハンマリッサ そのように私も死にますよと
マラナンママヘッセティ
死っていうことはずっと私をいじめているんだと
ウッパティアサヘーヴェダンマラナンアーカタンサダ
生まれたっていう瞬間と同時に死を受け取っているんだと
ワンセットで マラナッタイオー母さんワドコビエエーサティ
この死っていうのはずっと隙間を見ているんだと
私を殺すために まだ生きているのは
まだ隙間が見つからなかっただけなんです
イーサカンアニワッタンタン
放した矢は戻りませんね
そのように確実に死へ向かっていくんだ
そういう風にいろんな文章があります
日常起こる出来事よりも
自然に己の死を認めるべきなのです
例えば 日常の出来事っていうのは
そうならない可能性もありますよ
例えば皆様 この講義が終わったら電車に乗る
もう確実に乗れると思ってるでしょう
でもそうなれないこともありますよ
電車が事故を起こしたりとかね
突然電線切れたりとか
信号イカれたりとか そんなことはいくらでもあり得るんです
しかし それよりも自分が死ぬということが確かだよと
って認めてほしいんです
また 真理を認める人は強いということで
世間の美辞麗句は無知と精神的な弱みを応援する
世の中にあるあらゆる美辞麗句っていうのは
ただ我々の弱みを応援し
無知を応援しているだけなんですよ
死なない 死なないとかね
そんなこと言うなよとか
そんな暗いことを言うなよとか
なんとか言って あるいは不死なる魂
天国と永遠の命などの餌をまいて
人を弱みの罠にかける
いろんな餌までまくんです
どうせ死ぬんだぞとわかったら
やっぱりそれでも天国に命があるんだからとか餌をまくんです
最後の瞬間ででもバカで置いて置いておいたんですよ
騙したいんです ブッダの教えでは
事実を認める勇気と精神的な強さを必要とする
ブッダだけ逆に事実認めろという
その勇気を持ちなさいよと
勇気というのはですね
おかしい単語やと思いますけど
例えば地球が丸いと認めるために
別に当たり前のことだから
別に勇気も何のこともないでしょうに
だから物事は壊れて死ぬんだよっていうことは当たり前のことだから
勇気とかなんとかいうところじゃないんですよ
しかし 最初に地球が丸いと言ったところで大変なことになったでしょ
だから無知な人の中で真理を認めるということは大変なことなんです
だから勇気っていう言葉を使ったんです
ここまでいただけ 呼吸すると同じく死は当然なことだから
それを嫌がるものでも
避けるものでも 怯えるものでもなく
ありのままに認める 我々は息を吸ったら吐くでしょうに
それに誰か怯える それが不思議に思う
吸ったら吐く 吐いたら吸う
何のこともないでしょうに
死もまるっきり同じだと認められれば
もう相当な人間ですよ
はい まあ実証主義ということで
それで死を認めると すごく精神的には強くなる
生きることが不思議になる
奇跡的なことになる そうすると楽しくてたまらない
もう儲かったもんだから
宝くじが当たったような感じなんです
毎日 今日生きてるんだと
あら まだいるんだと 私たち仏教の仲間の挨拶でもよくしますよ
日本人と色々あまり慣れてないんですけど
私の友人の韓国のお坊さんがいて
もし電話でもかけてかけてきたら
私はあんたまだいるの？と
生きてるのかと それ全然失礼な単語でも何でもないです
それだけでお互いにふざけて楽しむ
楽しみますから 何か言い合って
僕は一見なりにものすごくびっくりした声で
あら まだ生きてるんですかねと
それは仏教的な事実で
そうなんですよと 不思議にまだ生きてるんだと
これを本気で認めると
日々すごい不思議なんです
そうなるとどうなるかというと
死は確定ですが その時刻
時刻は不確定ですね 今の瞬間からいつでも起こり得るものです
自覚 時刻は不確定だから
今の瞬間は生きてるんだからね
次の瞬間からいつでも死ねるんです
大事なのは この儚い命の管理なのです
だから このちょっとしたことで崩れるんだから
この泡みたいなもんだから
シャボン玉みたいなもんだからね
その管理が大事なんですよ
ほんのちょっとのことで弾けちゃいますからね
そちらに興味を持ってほしいんですよ
どう生きるかということに
ですから この瞬間たりとも無駄にしない
時間は 時間という言葉はいけないんですけど
いい加減なことをやる暇がないんです
無意味なことをやる暇もないんです
必要でないものには神経は使わない
何が有意義かと常に気をつける
次の瞬間死ぬかもしれません
だから この短い瞬間で何すればいいかという
そこら辺に興味を持つんですよ
それを実証主義ということなんです
死の瞬間を実践して このエージェンシーという
これパーリ語の専門用語がありますけどねという気持ちを育てる
まあエージェンシーというのは辞書を調べてみれば
この切迫した容姿とかね
急迫でしたっけ？緊急性
まあ火急とも書いてますけど
しかし 英語でこの problem of great agency ということは
日本訳で非常に緊急な問題というふうに日本訳しています
で その意味なんです だから
心の中に非常に緊急 待っていられないという
これすごいエネルギーなんですよ
火事の場力という言葉があるでしょ
火事になると 今の人にはその力がないんだけど
電話するだけで で 江戸時代だったらね
で もう火事があると もう何でもやるんですよ
一人一人人間がもう 100人の仕事でもする
もう10人でなければ運べない品物でも運ぶ
一人で あのエネルギーどこから来ているんですかというと
この火事だから来るんですよ
待っていられないんだから
ごちゃごちゃ妄想する暇がないんです
だからものすごい力が出てくるんです
それが仏教 お釈迦様が心理学的によく知って
この緊急性という その心であってほしいと
常に 死ねないと思った途端
ぼけーとするんです だからみんな怠け者です
はい 次 それで死をどのように観察するのかという
死の観察方法 すごい緊急性の精神になるために
こういう風に死を瞑想するんです
それから死の瞑想のやり方
死は無意識的にも認めたくない
ないことにしている事実なのです
仏弟子たちはそれを朝晩念じて忘れられないようにしなくてはならないのです
世の中は死はないことにしています
だから怠けて怠けていらんことばっかりやって
自分に迷惑 他人に迷惑
世界に迷惑 罪ばっかり起こしている
嫌な存在なんです お釈迦様は仏弟子たちには
あんなみっともない惨めな生き方をするなよと
朝晩自分が死ぬということは徹底的に観察しなさい
そのために釈尊が作った詩があります
この経典を読むことで無知が消え
事実を認める勇気が湧いてきます
心が清らかになります
この経典があります それは綺麗な声で読み上げるんです
意味を理解して ものすごいものすごい精密に作ってます
だからパーリ語自体はちょっと難しいところもありますけど
ものすごい美しいんですよ
読んだだけで感動するんです
すごい力が湧いてくるんです
はい それはこのサルスったれは何でしたっけ？あの漢字は
何経？え？うん まあでしょうね
サッラっていうのは 人を刺すものは何でもサッラと言うんですよ
あの まあ今は昔あったんですね
特別に包丁みたいなもの
これ人を刺すために作る
飛ばしちゃって 前 あ はいはいはいはい
サルスッタ アニミッタンアナンニャータンマッチャーナミダジービタンカシランチェパリッタンチェタンチェドゥッケーナサンユタン
暗記しなくちゃいけない経典ですけどね
アニミッタンアナンニャータンマッチャーナミダジービタンカシランチェパリッタン
タムチェ タンチェ ブッケーナ
サンユタン でももうカタカナ入れたりするとものすごくページ数が増えますからね
カットします 次に行きます
あれは意味はね ちょっとこれあの
もう学者が書いた意味なんですけど
私が頼んで訳してもらったんですけど
あまりにも難しすぎてちょっとわからないところもあります
私には読めない アニミッタンっていうのは
まあ印なし もう何の印もなく人は死ぬ
シリアス 宣告もしないで突然死ぬんです
こなる死すべき者どもが命で
だから我々の命っていうのは
まあそんなもんで 何の印もなくパッと死んでしまうんだよと
惨めなり 生きることはね
すごく惨めに生きているんだと
いわゆるアニミタナニャータンマッチャニ
カシランチャパリッタンチャ
カシランというのはやっと生きてるんだと
パリッタンというのはどうったこと？すごい少々という意味なんです
我々はやっていることでもほんのわずかなことしかできないんですよ
なんかだから惨めっていうことで
はかなし サマタ クニ 結束せよと
それから生きるということは
クニ 死ぬことは突然死んでしまいますが
生きること自体もろくなものではありませんと
ナヒソウ パッキャモアッティーエナジャータナミーヤリ
ジャランピパッ妥わマラナンエワンダンマヒパニノ
生まれた人を死なない
死を免れるためにはどんな方法もないんだよと
いかなる方法もないんだと
ジャランピパッとはマラナン
老いて それで死ぬんだと
それが法則ですと 免れる方法はないんだ
老いて死ぬんだよと これはすごい美しい声で歌うんですよ
それこそ幸福な歌であると
俗世間から見れば なんて暗い話でしょうと思うでしょう
そうじゃないんです はい
次 パラナミルパッカーナンパートパタナターバヤン
パタナトーバヤンパタナターバヤンとなんとか来ないと
パパとなればパラナニレパッカーナンパートパタナパパテナバヤン
エワンジャータナマッチャーナンニッチャンマナトウバヤン
パラナミレパッカーナンパートパタナターバヤンパートパパテナバヤン
ということは まあ熟した果物っていうのは必ず
落ちるんですね 早くに落ちる恐れがあるごとく
生まれたる死すべき者どもに
死の恐れ常にあり ヤタアピクンバカラスカタマッティックバージャナ
サッビーベーダナパリヤンタ
エワンマッチャーナジービタン
読めない たとえなに？例えば
陶工の作りたる陶器の一切が終いに廃人廃人に帰するごとく
次は覚は死すべき者どもが命なりと
で これあの陶工人とか何とか言っちゃって
ニュアンスが変わりますけど
これインドのグーグーだっちりどちらでも見る
このただの器を作る人々なんですよ
ただ土でもう器にして
ほんのちょっとの火で焼いて使うんです
食器として もうちょっと手でぶつけても壊れるんです
あのインドにいらっしゃったことがあった
あったならば まああのパック旅行ではなくて
一般的に行くならば この駅なんかではお茶売ってますでしょ
チャイとかね 何かちょっとしたカップに入れてくれますよ
あれも素焼きなんですね
飲んでそのまま捨てればいいんです
捨てて そしたら割れちゃうんです
硬くは焼かないんです
ほんのちょっとの火で焼くだけ
それがなんて日本の感覚から見れば
もう何何？なんだこんなことと思うかもしれませんだけど
でも インドの世界では自然を壊さないってことなの
結局は 簡単に土に戻ります
こちらで作る陶器はそうじゃないでしょう
壊れても土に戻れないんです
そのように簡単に壊れるんだと
人の命は 一応ＣＤ作ってきましたけど
これ入れたり止めたりしなくちゃいけないんだから
操作できるならば入れてはあります
あれ 芸一つ一つ止まってもらわないと
誰かボランティアがいるんでしょうかね
機械に詳しい  アニミッタンアナンニャータンマッチャーナンイタジータン
カシアンジャパリッタンジュタンジャドゥッケーナサンユクタン
ナイソーヴァッカモーワッティーレーナジャータナミーレー
ジャランピパッヴァマナナンデーワンダンマーイパニノー
パラナミヴァパッカーナンパートーパタラトーバヤン
デーワンマッチャーナマッチャーナンニッチャンマナトーバヤン
ヤターピクンバカーラッス
タターマッティカバージャナーサッベーヴェーダナパリヤンター
デーワンマッチャーナジービタン
で そういう風に読み上げます
次の芸に行きます  ダーラジャマハムタージャ
ジーバーラーヘーチャパンディター
サッベーマッチュワサンヤンティー
サッベーマッチュパラエナ
それでこの子供であろうが
年取ってる人であろうが
頭おろか者であろうが
賢者であろうが もうことごとくみんな死んでしまいますよと
データンマッチュパレーターナンガッチャタンパラローカト
ナピターターヤテープッタンナーティワパナナートケー
それで 何でしたか？かの死にえーと
読めない 破れ 高いに去りゆく者どもがためとて
父は息子を救うあたわす
親族も親族を救うあたわすと
だから誰にもどうすることもできない
父親には死んでいく子供を助けることもできないし
親族にもいくら待っていたって兄弟
自分の兄弟死んでいくのを何何することもできない
全く無力なんですよね
必ず死ぬんだよと だからすごくこの感動的に考えると
我々一緒に仲間で仲良くいたっても
誰にも誰を助けることもできないんだよと
死ぬんだよと はい 次に行きます
エクタムエーヴァナティーナンパスラールパタムブトー
エーカメコーマッチャーラムゴワッジョーリアニーヤティー
それで見よというなんかいいな
親族をのミスへ泣き叫ぶ中
凡夫は一人また一人死すべき者どもより
えっ？引きさらわれる
飛ばに光る牛の如し そこであの親族が見ているのに
例えば親族はベッドに寝ていて死にかけてますよ
それでみんな周りでずっと見ているんですよ
普通の人の死はね 例えば親が死にかけている
母親 父親か で 子供と孫たちがずっとベッドの周りにじーっと待ってるんですよ
何をすることもできないんですね
悲しいんだけど どうどうすることもできない
ただ死んでいくのを待つしかないんですね
もうそれがこの牛を殺しにもう引っ張っていくと
他の牛たちやらみんな待ってるんだけど
どうすることもできないんですね
じゃあ今日はこの牛を屠殺するぞと思っちゃうと
その人が捕まって引っ張っていって殺すでしょ
牛たちは一緒に生活しているんですよ
お互い仲良く でもどうすることもできない
我々の命もそんな感じで
なんか屠殺場に決めている牛たちのような命なんですよ
誰が誰が引っ張られるかわからない
それを止めることもできない
止まることもできない
はい 次に行きます  えーアンナーどーこーマチュラージュだーやっちゃった
スマディーラーね ソーチャンティーヴィニトワードッカパリアヤ
このこの世の中っていうのは
このように大変なものであるとね
ちょっと読んでみてください
各死により老いにより
世の生命は責めうたる
責めうたるということでね
もういつでも迫られてますよ
かるが故に 世の生命が有様を知り
有様を知り 賢者は悲しみます
これはね 元の訳をちょっと変えたんです
変えるところはいくつかありましたから
まああまり変えてないんですけど
賢者は悲しまないんだと
こんなものやと 世の中はと
はい 八十八二番目  マッカーナジャーナジータグタッスラタッスワーウボアンテーラサンパッサンニラッタンパリデーヴァシー
それで えっと どう読むのですか？消し消しものさりもの
彼者が道を汝は知らず
死生および生まれる以前の両辺を承前接して
えっ 召還接して 汝は無為に憂う
これで意味はわからなくなりますけど
我々は人が死んだということで泣くやわめきますが
彼の道は知らない どこから来たやつかと
例えば自分の子供が死んでる
悲しいんですよ しかし
この子供 こいつはどこから自分のお腹の中に入ったのかとわからないでしょうに
それから死んでどこに行ったかと
それもわからないんですよ
突然来て出て行っただけ
我々みんなそうなんですよ
突然この世の中で現れてきて
突然出て行っちゃうんですよ
しかし 周りの人々は悲しんじゃうんです
だからもう悲しんじゃっても意味がないんだと
例えば皆様の家に突然知らない人が来て
ちょっとあっちこっち見てまた帰っちゃったら悲しくもないでしょうに
そんな感じで見てくださいと
自分の子供の死に対しても
親の死に対しても 兄弟の死に対しても
どこから来たかわからへんやつやと
まだどこへ行ったかわからへんなと
勝手にしろよと 自分も同じやと周り
例えば周りのことを気にして死にきれないとかね
そんな関係ないんです
たとえ奥さんがいても
子供がいても 孫がいたってもどうったことない
自分も突然来たんだからね
突然出ていけばあんた方と関係ないんだよという態度で見なくちゃいけないんです
はい  パリデーウェーマーロービーヒンディーダッタンモダッガー
サモロヒンサマッターナンカリラーセナンウィジャッケノー
それで足りねば今 泣いて泣いて泣いて憂いでね
何かあなた方は得するんでしょうかと
まあまあ それはまあ 憂いと言ったって
パリデーヴァというのは泣くことなんですけどね
ものすごく涙流して声出して泣くことにパリデーヴァと言うんです
で そんな風にものすごく泣いて泣いて
あなた方は何か得でもするのかと
さ 得はこれだけ サモロヒンサマッターナ
なんて言いますか もう頭がおかしくなるだけ
自分をさらに自分を損なう
愚昧者に 何ほどの利がもし得られるならば
賢者もその憂いを行うが良いと
もし泣いて泣いて何か得があれば
賢者も泣きもいいんですよ
馬鹿にしてるんですよ
もう人が死んで泣く人のこと
もし人の死別れに我々は悲しくて
もう泣き崩れることによって得る利益があるんだったら
みんなで泣きましょうと
それいたところで思い出したことがあります
で この南アメリカの おそらくブラジルとかそこら辺のどこかの国なんですけど
人が死んだら泣くべきだと思って商売にしているんです
それで泣き女とかがいて
その人々にお金を払っちゃえば
もう葬式終わるまで 神父さんがなんとかなんとかなんだらかんだら言うまで終わるまでものすごく泣いて
あの場をね むちゃくちゃにして
それでお金を持って帰るんです
泣かなかったら格好悪いと思っているんです
それで面白いことに 自分の国でもこの空港とこの観光客がいる
行って泊まる観光リゾートあるところがありまして
二願部と呼ぶんですけど
カトリック教の教地ですけど
仏教の人ほとんど一人もいないぐらい
そこら辺でもなんかその習慣があるみたいです
そこで我々は冗談で言うんです
我々の仏教の田舎ではね
お前泣いたらこの二願部から女を呼べなくちゃいけないんだよと言うんです
お前が死んだっていうのを馬鹿にしているんです
悪いことしているんだからね
誰を悲しませようと お前みたいな悪いやつがという感じでも
だいたい子供に言うことなんですけど
お前なんか死んじゃったらね
もう二願部から女を呼ばないと
ということで言うんです
だから いかに泣くことっていうのはバカバカらしいかっていうことも入ってるし
まあ人いい加減に生活しなさいという躾
戒めも入って そういうことはあります
自分の国では この田舎の人々は
昔は人が亡くなると この
ヴェッサンテラジャータク物語があります
それは歌にしているんです
すごい感動的なジャータク物語なんです
それを歌にして それを読み上げるんです
それをプロがいて ずっと葬式
例えば 1日 2日 ぐらいになったりすると
すーっと止まることなく読み上げる
で なんでそれを読み上げるかというと
それでもう泣く代わりなんです
泣かなくてもいいやと
そのジャータカ物語りに
あの親しき人と別れることは大変な苦しいことであると
しかし 菩薩は何のことなく別れたんだよという物語なんです
で その物語で この菩薩はこの布施を実践するんですね
あるこの浮浪者というかね
まあ乞食なんですけど
バラモン人が来て まああんたは何でもおするでしょうと
だから私に奴隷にあなたの子供二人これと言うとあげたんです
で 子供は奴隷 奴隷にするってことは明確に知っている
何もお金もない人であるという乞食であることも知っている
そこっていうのは  現代人の思考から見れば
ちょっと考えにくいかもしれませんだけど
でもストーリーはきちんと論理的に成り立っています
まず王様でいて 何でもあげる
何でもあげる で 国民がすごく腹が立っている
国が倒れるんだと そんなことしたらと
で 国の中にあげたりしたんだから
そこまでは我慢していたんです
それで隣の国から この宝物の象がいたんです
すっごい立派な象で 白い色で
で この象がいるんだが
命の名神で だから国がすごい幸福だと
幸せやと で 隣の国は自分たちは経済的に豊か
恵まれてないんだから
あの王様からあの象をもらいましょうと
そうすると この象のもう何て言いますか
この 力で私たちの国も幸せになるだろうということで
そう 象をちょうだいと言ったんです
これは国の財産で 国民の財産でもある
王様使ってるんだからといって
王様のところに飼っているんだからといって
王様の個人所有物じゃないんです
で このウェスタンっていう王様が
菩薩が向きからはい あげますと
で 正式的に渡しちゃったんです
それに国民は怒ったんです
この人は王にいると困ると
で 追放したんです まだ父親がいたんです
それでまだ父親は年なんですけど
しょうがないんだから
もう一度世間を逃げてくださいと
息子はもうダメやと 危ないんだと
何をあげるかわからないんだと
人にと それで息子が追放されたところで
あ よかったと 私は全国まで捨てますよということで
ヒマラヤ山脈に入って修行するんですね
そうすると奥さんと子供二人も一緒に行くんです
私たちも一緒に行くんだと
菩薩はやめなさい やめなさいと
あんた方にはこの森の中で生活できんと
私の修行にも邪魔やというと
奥さんは聞かない お妃は
私はあなたから離れて 1 日も居ませんと
あなたは行くんだったら
自分が死んでやるぞと
ということで一緒に行ったんです
一緒に行って まあちゃんと菩薩は修行する
お妃もちゃんと修行する
しかし 子供二人の面倒も見なくちゃいけない
それを見ながら子供もすくすくと森の中で育てる
だから子供に他の人間いないんだから
二人がものすごい仲がいい
そこであの乞食のバラモンがその話を聞いて
ヒマラヤ山脈まで上がったんです
自分が若奥さんと結婚して
若い女の人と子供の人は家の仕事をやりたくない
だから召使い連れてこいと
我々貧乏人に召使いいるわけじゃないんだと言ったところで
だってあの王様はなんでもあげるんだから
子供いるでしょうに 言ったらくれると
ということで 行ったところであげちゃったんです
で あげたところで この菩薩はものすごい悲しいんだけど
いきなり子供の顔を見ないであげて
すぐ他の方を見ていたんだと
それで子供二人も父親の気持ちをわかっているんだから
まあ父親がものすごいこの自分の心と闘っているんだと
だから我々は母父に何の迷惑をかけないで喜んで行った方がいいんだと
いて喜んで行ったんで
その場で捕まって盗んで
もうもう鞭で打ちながら
今からこの王子王子ですからね
男の子と女の子が こいつは威張ってるかもしれない
今からもう殴って もう奴隷やということはもう覚悟させないとあかんということで
殴ったりして連れて行ったんですね
で 連れて行ったところで
まあ自分の国に戻ったところで
国民が分かったんです
子供二人で この人にはまあ奴隷
人間買うぐらい能力はないんだと
顔を見たら これはもう王様の息子で娘なんですね
で 国民はさっさと父親に言って
父親というのは この子供のおじい様なんですね
大変なことになっているんだから
もう戻しなさいと 孫二人ぐらいでも
言うと 王様がその人を呼んで
このこれは私の孫ですから返せと
返せません 私はもらったもんだからと
言うと その子供二人の重さに重さを量って金をくれるんだったらということで金をあげたんです
量ってあげて 孫二人を返してもらったんです
で そこでまあ そのジャータカ物語ってちょっと長いジャータカ物語なんですけど
このいかに悲しみをなくすべきかっていうところで
この子供たちはこうやって泣いてるとかね
で それで一番あるのはこのお妃の泣き声なんです
これ かなり長い作品で
お妃はいろんなことを歌ですからね
もう泣いてる姿をね それでも私は忍耐しますと
子供がいないこの森はとても寂しいんだと
花も全然美しく見えないんだと
鳥の声もものすごく気持ち悪く聞こえるんだと
それで私は執着を捨てるべきということで忍耐しますというふうな歌なんです
そういうことを歌って
悲しみをなくすということになっているんです
それは一般の田舎の人々で昔やっていたこと
今はそういう習慣はほとんどないんです
それで知識人の間では
仏教的には人が亡くなったらこの四念処経を唱えるということが普通なんです
四念処経というのは瞑想の経典なんですね
それは別に死にということに何のことにも入ってないんですけど
瞬間瞬間 自分の生き方を気づくことしか人間にやるべきことはないという
これ深い真理なんです
そういうことをやっています
ですから お釈迦様は人が死んで亡くなることはちょっともう茶化してるんです
泣いて何か得するのかと
得するんだったらみんなで泣きましょうと
私も一緒に泣いてあげますよという気持ちで言ってるんです
はい 次に行きます  ナヒルンメーナソーケーネサンティンパッポーティテータソーヴィアッスッパッジャテードゥッカムサリーランドゥーパハンヤティー
まあそういうことで 泣いても泣いても全然心は安らぎには静寂にはならないんだと
さらに苦しくなり 苦しくなるだけですよと
体も壊れちゃって 次に行きます
キソーウィマンノーバヴァーティーインサマッターマッターナーナテーナペーターパーレンティーニラッターパリデーヴァナー
それでこの泣いちゃった
死んだ人はなんで死んだんだろうと泣いたりすることで
結局は体も痩せるわ 肌色も悪くなるわ
自分 自分自身を損するんだと
かなり損なんですよ 自分の命には
次にこの意味はちょっと変わっているような
このナテーナペーターパーレンという３行目ありますね
泣いたんだからといって
これは供養になりませんよと
死んだ人のために ナテーナペーターパーレンというのは
死んだ人には何の役にも立たないんだと
あなたは泣いても悲しがっても
で だから 悲しむことは意味がない
喜ぶ 憂うことは意味がないんだよと
...ちょっと読んでください
比丘をたたずるもの いやましくを憂く
亡き者を嘆くもの 比丘の力にとらわれたりと
まあこういう悲しみを立てないんだったら
さらにさらにあなたは苦しむんだよと
あのっとなんと変わらかった
死んだ人のことはごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ思うと
どんどんどんどん自分も悲しみに陥ってしまうし
だから自分の短い命が無駄になるだけですよという意味なんです
発音はこのスリランカのテキストでメインにしていましたから
いろいろちょっとちょっと変わっているところはありますけど
で 見ようと 他の人々を見ようと
みんなこの自分の業によって死んでいくんでしょうと
あなたの子供だけじゃない
あなたの親だけじゃないんだと
あなたの兄弟だけじゃないんだと
世の中見てみようと 見てみなさいよ
みんなそれぞれ自分の行いによって死んでいくんではないかと
死に出向くと パンダンテミダの人々は本当にもう怖くなるんですよ
怖い怖いっていうことに関係なく
みんなまあ死んでいくんだよ
死への付近 刺激の近く来て
うん  現状にいて打ち震える
打ち震える 処理をみんなこの震えながら死んでいくんですよ
やっぱり屠殺場に連れて行く動物と全く同じなんです
屠殺場に連れて行く動物というのはみんな震えるんです
皆様が見ていないだけで
見るともう絶対もう肉なんか食べる気にはならないんです
動物はどれほど怯えて震えるかというと
その怯え震えっていうのは
自分たちにも他の生命にもみんなにあります
死ぬのは怖いもんなんですね
生命には だからあんたは自分の誰か誰かの死に泣くんじゃなくて
世の中見てみれば もうどっちもみんなそういうことであると見てみなさいということ
です 耶那耶那曼ガンティ
タトタンホーディアンジャタ
エターディソーヴィナーバウカッスローカッスパリヤーヤン
それでイエーナイエーナヒマンニャンティ
我々はあれこれとはいろんなことを期待
考えてはするんですけど
実はタトタンホーディアンジャタ
我々の期待通りには一つもいかないんだと
あれによってこれによってと人は思えど
それはそれ 思いより異なりてならしならぬですからね
生死の別れもかくの如し
見よ 世の衆生の有様をと
生命の有様をと だから死んで欲しくないんだけど
死にますよと 年取って欲しくないと思っても年取る
商売繁盛したいと思ってもそうはならない
だから我々は何の期待しなくても
実は反対だけが起こってしまうんですね
だからその世の中の法則はそんなもんだであると理解しなさいよということで
アビヴァッササタンディーヴェーディーリョーアパナマナウォ
ニャーティサンガーヴィナーホーティガーティイダディーヴィタン
たとえ人が万が一百年ぐらいいても
あるいはより長く生きても
いつか親族より別離してもと
まあ必ず死ななくちゃいけない
たとえ百年頑張ったんですけど
百年以上生きてみたっても別れますよと
で そこでちょっとこの日本訳に入ってないんですけど
ちょっと別のニュアンスもありますよ
百歳まで生きて幸せかというと
ちょっとそうじゃないんですよ
百歳 百二十歳までいるとどうなるかというと
自分の親戚が死んでいくんですよ
だから長生きする人がいろんな人の死を経験しなくちゃいけないんです
親が百二十歳までいたんだからといって
子供も百二十歳にならないでしょ
だから親が自分の子供の死を迎えなくちゃいけない
孫の死を見なくちゃいけない
他の兄弟の死を見なくちゃ
だから長生きするということはそう幸せじゃないんです
本当にすごく寂しいんですよ
周りの人々が亡くなると
それが年下になってくると
ものすごく信じられないほど寂しいんです
年上の人が亡くなると
もうなんとか我慢できますけど
だから仏教から見ると
ただ長生きできてなんて幸せかっていうのはなくて
その人は結構大変です
長生きしたっても やっぱり全部それで死ななくちゃいけないんだと
タスマハラトスットワ
ウィネーヤパリデービタン
ペータンカーラカタンディッスワ
ネソーラッバハマヤイティ
ちょっと発音も間違りますけど
タスマハラトスットワ
ウィネーヤパリデービタン
ペータンカーラカタンディッスワ
ネソーラッバハマヤイティ
ネソーっていう風にも文法的にはなりますけどね
それで アラハトスット
阿羅漢たちのこの言葉を聞きなさい
例えば あの今までの歌を見ると
なんか失礼な乱暴なことではないかと思えるかもしれませんよ
だからブッダがそこら辺で強調するんですよ
これは聖者の言葉だよと
聖者の歌なんです お釈迦様が作った歌なんです
お釈迦様の言葉なんです
だから真剣に聞きなさいよと
理解しなさいよと 理解して心に生まれる憂い
悲しみをなくせと ペータンカーラカタンディッスワ
死んだ人を見て まあ私は死ぬわけないんだと思うなよと
ということなんですね
亡き者 寂しい者を見て
かの者もはや我に得られずと
そんなことを思ってはいけないんだと
はい 回してください  ヤターサレナマーディッタン
ワーリナーパリニッパエー
エーワンピティーローサッパンノー
パンディトークサローナロー
ピッパモッパティサンソーカン
ワートゥートーランワダンセー
それで こちらで最後の例えがもう一つありますけどね
あの なんて言いますか
あたかも燃えたる住居でしたっけ？住居の水により消し去るがごとく
で まあ家に火がついちゃったら水をかけて消すでしょうね
だから まあこれはあの同義語ばっかりですね
サッパンの智慧のある人は
賢者はまあ有為者とかね
智者っていう人が まあまあ先行者とか
それは全部直訳で同義語を直訳しています
悲しみをすぐたちまち消しますよと
ワートゥートーランワダンセー
火性の燃火を吹き払うこと
で そんなふうな感じでサッと悲しみを捨ててしまえと
悲しむとこじゃないんだと
そんなの当たり前だということです
パリデーワンバジャッパンチェ
ドゥーマナサンチャアッタノー
アッタノーสุขメダーノー
アッバディーサッラマッタノー
そこでこのサッラという言葉が来るんです
この言葉をとって経典の名前をつけてるんです
えーと 自身の憂いを 悲窮ですか
何ですかね 悲窮を 苦悩を引き抜くが良い
引き抜いてくださいと
自身の楽を尋求するならば
自身の矢を引き抜くが良い
これを死は認めないということが悲しみの原因なんですよ
死は当たり前 だから死は認めないという
あの無知が心に刺している
この矢のごとく 槍のごとく刺されているんです
ずっと だから 親しい人が死んでも死ななくても
我々ははこの矢で苦しんでいるんです
人は死なないんだと 私は死なないという気持ちが
その気持ちにサッラ 矢というんです
針というんです 死なないという無知に
だからこれは抜いてくださいと心から
アッブーラサッローアディトーサンテンパッコリヤジェータドー
サッバソーカンアティッカントー
アソーコホーティニブトーティ
はい それでその経典の最後の
アッブーラサッロー もうこの矢をね
抜いてしまえば 心はすごく安らかになるんだと
サッバソーカンが一切の苦しみをもう乗り越えますよと
一切の悲しみをね 一切の悲窮を乗り越えるもの
そこでアソーコホーティニブトー
悲しみなく 悲窮なく 寂滅する
ニブトーというのは涅槃のことで
涅槃を経験できますよと
悟れますよという意味なんです
完全たる安らぎを得られますよということで
仏教の人々はそのようにじりじりと自分の死を
人の死をそのまま認める
訓練するんですよ この訓練しなきゃできない
我の頭がもう無知でできているんだから
妄想でいっぱいだから
だからくだらない妄想をしないで
こういう考え方で頭いっぱいにするんです
だから私たちなんか冗談ででもどこ行くのかと
死行くんだよと 平気で言う
もうただ日常茶飯事の冗談にまでなっているという
はい じゃあそれで疲れたと
休憩取りますかね 話はまだ半分です